terrible news in the world of politics
the birthday party is over at least for
now
kanye west has dropped out of the 2020
presidential race and i have to tell you
as excited as I was and enthusiastic
about Kanye's campaign I had a feeling
this might happen part of the reason
that I had this feeling was that Kanye
has released to my knowledge only one
videoed statement on the campaign and
that statement did not exactly inspire
confidence it was everybody I'm here at
the county clerk's office I wanted to
show you how I just registered to vote
see that was the issue the I just
registered to vote apparently for the
first time does not make me think that
the campaign was in the best shape to
get all the paperwork filed do all the
right campaign and get get everything in
place a lot of campaigns are up in the
air right now
Jeff Sessions got wiped out in Alabama
big shake shape-ups at the Trump
campaign numbers from polling all over
the place
Kanye we hardly knew ye
but it's anybody's race I'm Michael
Knowles is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
lots going on specifically in politics
you know very often we're talking about
the culture and how the cultural issues
are going to affect politics well the
effects are here the campaign's are
getting into high gear and some very
important changes are being made before
we get into that you know we spoke
yesterday about Nick Cannon who is now
spouting black supremacist rhetoric
about how white people are animals I
that the the most insightful comment
yesterday from the entire audience came
on this topic of the power of melanin
and that was I always feel smarter and
more compassionate when I am tanned come
January or February I'm a beast I feel
that way too and occupying this sort of
middle ground in America as a Sicilian
American I guess depending on the time
of the year I in particular will have
more soul more compassion be less like
an animal well we'll get into a little
bit of that too once we get past the
politics we will get into the broader
cultural context now I have to thank our
friends over at keeps you know two out
of three guys will experience hair loss
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they are 35 we were talking
about where all of our power comes from
you know at least 80% of my powers
derived from my hair that is why my
youtube channel blew past clavin's you
know I just I need it and the best way
to prevent hair loss is to do something
about it while you still have a hair
left you used to have to go to the
doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription now thanks to keeps you can
visit a doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered right to your home
prevention is key keeps treatments can
take up to four to six months or more to
see results so it's important to act
fast the sooner you start using keeps
the more hair you will save find out why
keep says more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors and nearly
100,000 men trust keeps for their hair
loss prevention medication it's so
simple you just got to do it and the
sweet ones started just ten dollars for
for each month and your your first month
will be free for a limited time if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair
goto keeps calm / anoles KO wles to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that is ke eps calm / knowles
so major shakeups beyond the kanye
presidential collapse this on the Trump
campaign President Trump has out stood
his campaign manager Brad parse Cal he
out stood parse Cal and he promoted this
guy named Bill Stepien what does this
mean it means what we've known for a
long time which is that the Trump
campaign was veering in the wrong
direction
and it needed to correct course and it
did correct course not a moment too soon
we are now less than four months away
from the presidential election so it's
it these sorts of changes had to happen
you know on this show when I have
criticized certain things that the White
House of the campaign is doing i I like
to point out that that it most likely
it's that the president is getting bad
advice now I don't know if the problems
were parse calls fault the issue however
is that on a presidential campaign the
buck stops at the top and so if there
were problems even further down the line
it's that campaign managers job to deal
with those problems and obviously
President Trump thought that poor Scott
would be in a better position elsewhere
the thing to know about what's happened
know and don't forget in 2016 Trump
shook up his campaign management
constantly you know all these different
names that came up Cory Lewandowski
Steve ban and Kellyanne Conway they were
all coming up they were all churning the
whole time that that's in part I think
how he was able to to continue to
improve his campaign just because you
start out and it's a little weak doesn't
mean you have to end that way Brad parse
Cal who was running the Trump campaign
was the campaign's digital director in
2016 and the Trump campaign did great on
digital in 2016 but just because you can
do one job on a campaign extraordinarily
well does not mean that you can
necessarily run a campaign
extraordinarily well in fact in many
ways those are completely different jobs
you know one is much more about
management the other is much more
creative so the guy that he's replaced
him with this guy bill Stepien is a
political veteran and crucially he's run
of campaigns and he ran chris cristie's
to successful gubernatorial campaigns
did not run the unsuccessful
presidential but he ran the two
successful gubernatorial ones I'm
pleased to see this change no no ill
will toward Brad parks Calvin I'm glad
to see the Trump is listening and
realizes that things were not going as
well as they should be because if if the
campaign I think were to continue in
this way he might be headed for an
unhappy day in November
these things happen nobody is guaranteed
to be re-elected nobody is guaranteed to
get their seat back Jeff Sessions
learned this lesson the hard way down in
Alabama Jeff Sessions who served in the
Senate for I think 300,000 years I mean
he was there he was there for a very
long time he left to become Trump's
Attorney General then Trump soured on
him as Attorney General he ran for his
old seat again and he lost and he didn't
didn't lose just by a little bit it was
a pretty clear loss here is sessions
conceding the people of Alabama I want
to thank you for your support over the
years we've fought a good fight in this
race and we've taken that case to the
people of Alabama and the people of
Alabama have spoken they want a new
leader a new fresh face to go to
Washington I think we're going to have
that I love this state it's been an
honor beyond words for me to serve it I
want to congratulate Tommy Tuberville he
ran a really firm solid race he was
focused on his goal and on winning he
had a plan to do so and he was able to
do so
he is our Republican nominee we must
stand behind him in November so a very
gracious concession speech from Jeff
Sessions you know increasingly in recent
years people don't want to actually
admit that they lose elections that's
why you have Stacey Abrams is still the
shadow governor of Georgia and all these
sorts of things people don't want to
admit when they lose Hillary Clinton
still thinks she's the president but but
sessions has admitted this this is good
news for Trump this signals that Trump's
endorsement still has a fair bit of sway
at least in a bright red state like
Alabama because
Trump furious at Jeff Sessions as tenure
as AG that came out very strongly for
Tommy Tuberville the reason I think why
sessions was so gracious about this it's
not only because he's a nice polite man
but also because he got blown out of the
water the race was not even closed
sessions won only three out of Alabama's
67 counties Tommy Tuberville got 61% of
the vote that to Jeff Sessions is 39% so
what does it all mean for Trump we don't
know very much about Tommy Tuberville we
know a lot about Jeff Sessions he was a
very popular senator but that that Trump
movement seems to add some influence
nobody knows anything so you know the
minute that someone tells you this is
exactly what's going to happen in
November immediately discount what
they're saying this is up in the air and
I think this is the the point about
politics no one wants to admit but it's
the point that the actually should give
us the most hope which is that nothing
is inevitable okay with the left wants
you to believe is that it's absolutely
inevitable the Democrat Joe Biden is
gonna win in 2016 it was inevitable
Hillary was gonna win 98% chance 99%
chance and it's not it's up in the air
it's politics they have a ton of
institutional power but they don't have
all of the power we the people still
have a lot of power we can send them a
message every so often we can do it not
just here it happened in the brexit vote
it's happened all around the West there
is some popular uprising there is some
popular power and there is a poll out
from Monmouth University Polling
Institute which is an independent
polling Institute that shows very good
news for Trump on this front it shows
that the people have more power and
they're playing their cards a little
closer to their chests than they then
they might be letting on the poll is a
little bit complicated to read the
conclusions of the Poehler a little bit
complicated to get but what it basically
says is that people don't want to be
honest with pollsters people don't want
to tell everyone that they're voting for
Trump and it's not just the the same
story we heard in 2016 that phenomenon
has actually increased it's been
exacerbated people are more like
to keep quiet about their support for
Trump most registered voters 54% say
they were surprised in 2016 when Trump
ended up winning
Pennsylvania's electoral votes they
currently are about divided on where on
where Pennsylvania's gonna go this time
46 or 45 percent one reason is that 57%
believe there are a number of so-called
secret voters in their communities who
support Trump but won't tell anyone
about it and less than half that number
27% believe that there are secret voters
for Biden so realize you eat on a pole
you can't ask people are you a secret
voter for Trump because if by definition
if you tell the pollster that you're a
secret order for Trump then you're no
longer a secret voter for Trump so the
way the question is phrased is about
other people do you believe that there
are secret voters for Trump and so our
conclusions here are not totally firmly
consider the black lives matter
phenomenon which is the when someone
uploads a black square to social media
or someone uses the hashtag black lives
matter what they're saying is that I
believe black lives matter but a lot of
people do not however everybody has used
this phrase and everybody has said that
black lives matter so that would be an
example of people imagining that there
are all these sort of phantoms out there
but but realizing that they actually
there are not right I mean you know we
have to see there or not there's not a
scourge of Klansmen running around the
country so the question with this poll
is or the people who are saying they
believe there are a lot of secret Trump
voters out there is it just a delusion
or they're really do they have good
reason to think there are the secret
voters I think it's the latter I think
this is good news for the Trump campaign
because the fact is everybody knows a
trump voter and if frankly everybody
knows a secret Trump voter who doesn't
want to lose his job who doesn't want to
lose his career and his livelihood this
this issue of punishment for support of
Trump has increased over the last
several years and certainly during these
race riots and the fact of the matter is
that you know Trump did win about half
the country voted for him in 2016 so
there all are a lot of these people does
not mean Republicans should get
complacent more good polling news
Rasmussen shows Trump has ticked up
seven points nationally narrowed Biden's
laid the three point
in recent days so Joe Biden right now is
at 47% and among us likely voters Trump
is at 44 percent 5% prefer another
candidate and 4% or undecided it's
anybody's game it's anybody's race
don't let anybody tell you otherwise
don't let anybody intimidate you into
giving up and staying home and being
locked up staying home whether because
you're afraid to go outside and breathe
the fresh air or staying home more
specifically on politics because you
don't feel that your vote will matter in
the election that is what the left is
banking on now there is a cultural
aspect to all of this as well the
culture elicits has become absolutely
insane particularly on the subject of
race you thought Nick Cannon was bad
yesterday talking about how white people
are animals a friend of his an even more
famous friend of his in the mainstream
entertainment industry came out and
defended him a little bit of a double
standard kind of reminds me probably not
a whole lot of white supremacy going on
we'll get to that in one second first I
got to thank our friends over at We the
People pollsters you know if you have a
good hand gun but no holster you're just
not doing gun ownership right okay you
got to be safe and you got to get an
excellent holster starting at just $39
we the people holsters are custom
designed to fit your firearm perfectly
they're made right here in the US of A
they have thousands of options to choose
from plus an amazing selection of
printed holsters their proprietary clip
design allows for you to easily adjust
both the can't and ride of your holster
so that it will fit comfortably and
securely at all times I've loved this
company for years now I think they make
an incredible product and I think now
more than ever is the time to support
American companies it's a pretty
patriotic imagine exercising your Second
Amendment rights while using an American
company if it's just it's perfect it's
beautiful go to we the people holsters
dot-com / Knowles to get yours every
holster ships free comes with a lifetime
guarantee and by the way you get an
additional 10 bucks off with the promo
code Knowles canna wles
so that brings it down what - like -
twenty nine dollars it's unbelievable
satisfaction guaranteed if it's not a
perfect that send it back for a total
refund we the people holsters dot-com /
Knowles
people holsters dot-com / Knowles offer
code Knowles the cultures become nuts
particularly on race I think that's why
people are now even less likely to admit
that they're willing to to vote for the
Republican candidate there's so much
racial demagoguery we had the Nick
Cannon talk yesterday where Nick Cannon
said white people are savages and
barbaric and soulless and animals
well Puff Daddy P diggity do dad is
coming out and defending him P P diddles
tweeted out quote Nick Cannon has come
home to
Nick Cannon come home to revolt TV truly
black owned we got your back and love
you and what you have done for the
culture we are for our people first for
us by us let's go can you so the stuff
that Nick Cannon said yesterday it's
pretty disgusting stuff about how
terrible white people are how they don't
have souls but how you get power from
melanin and your skin and because white
people don't have that they're animals
and now you've got an even more
mainstream guy P Diddy coming out in
defending them imagine if this were
reversed imagine if a popular white
musician tweeted at I don't know Richard
Spencer or David Duke or somebody and
said David Duke come home to revolt TV
truly white owned yes with a thumbs up
I'm you know white thumbs up emoji we
got your back we love what you do and
what you've done for the culture we are
for white people first for us by us
let's go
probably that wouldn't go over very well
would it in the culture and yet we are
told this lie that we are living in a
white supremacist nation of course that
is not the case we've gone over this on
this show many other times the the
there's there's one aspect of our law
that is still racially discriminatory as
a matter of law that is called
affirmative action and that
disadvantages does an advantage it
disadvantages white people and Asian
people particularly on university
admissions which is why a group of Asian
students sued
Harvard University that's it that's the
only one if you're told that there is
white supremacy by law you're being lied
to and even in the culture no sort of
nonsense like this if it were if it were
posted by white people would would ever
be tolerated you would lose your life
you would lose your livelihood without
question I did we're for our people for
something like that crazy and yet we are
living under this delusion actually that
you know these these polls and these
polls about how people think one thing
and they think other people think
another thing and they think other
people think that other people think
another thing we're all trying to guess
where everybody is because we are living
in a properly ideological vision and the
ideologies is disconnected from the
reality in many cases so you're going to
see more of this this is increasingly
what politics is going to become about
you already seeing it in Asheville North
Carolina Asheville North Carolina first
place in the country to now officially
vote for reparations for slavery
Asheville voted seven to nothing so a
total unanimous vote at the City Council
to formally apologize to black residents
for the city's role in slavery and other
racist policies throughout history I
guess I guess the residence maybe they
thought that the town was happy about
slavery or something so they had to
issue this formal apology 150 years
after the abolition of slavery and the
measure calls to provide reparations to
black residents in the form of
investments in their community such as
increasing minority homeownership
increasing minority business ownership
and career opportunities now obviously
this is this is racial discrimination
because you're giving certain advantages
to people based on the color of their
skin so it's not certainly not white
supremacy but it's we have seen this
kind of thing before particularly in
affirmative action and similar policies
but it should it should be noted that
this is not what people mean by
reparations the the black residents of
this town are not going to get direct
payments it's just going to be another
welfare program it's just going to be
another affirmative action program the
likes of which we've seen for the past
50 years none of which have worked it
hasn't what we're just going to get more
of the same this is
one marketing piece of genius that we've
seen from the left in recent years is
they are repackaging their old stupid
policies that don't work
they're just repackaging them and making
them seem fresh and new none of these
programs forget even race for a moment
the green New Deal
none of these giant government programs
are anything really new they are just
vast expansions of policies that were
already in place just regular old
welfare programs regular old power grabs
by people who are exploiting our fears
on the son monster you know the
environment or race or whatever and
probably we can expect the same results
again but now we're all focused on race
and the results of it if you are living
in the ideology if you were living in
the world in which the Klan is running
around and towns are still happy about
slavery 150 years later and we have
white supremacy then you you don't
notice the absurdity but if you're a
normal person you do there was a new set
of guidelines that was just put out by
the National Museum of african-american
history and culture
it was describing aspects and
assumptions of whiteness and white
culture do you know what the National
Museum of african-american history and
culture believes to be explicitly and
exclusively white cultural aspects
individualism that's the first one
family structure having a mother and a
father is white apparently black people
they don't have that the scientific
method I'm not joking they put this out
there science is white I don't I guess
shamanism or something soothsaying
would be black or for other people of
color but white people have a
stranglehold on science history history
is an aspect of whiteness in white
culture the Protestant work ethic were
working like getting up and doing your
job that is now exclusively a white
cultural aspect according to this
african-american museum religion
Christian Christianity that is
exclusively white perhaps they should
read the book hazy giving you imagine
what's gonna happen when they read the
Gospels future orientation so planning
ahead for the future that's white black
people can't do that I guess they're
just stuck in the in the eternal present
time time is listed on here is
exclusively white aesthetics like beauty
beauty it's like I've I can't I actually
cannot believe I cannot allow myself to
believe that this was put out seriously
by by a nominal group of African
American the National Museum of African
American history is David Duke running
the National Museum of african-american
history is this like a Richard Spencer
like joke project holidays justice
competition all-white crazy that's crazy
and very offensive to black people but
when you're when you're stuck in this
kind of ideological framework you can't
notice that in this world even
mainstream reporters are asking even in
interviews with the President of the
United States this kind of madness this
sort of thing do you do you believe that
black lives matter asking President
United States do you condemn the police
who are killing all these black people
which by the way isn't happening not
happening at all so in that world
President Trump
mmm mainly alone possibly alone among
his contemporaries is willing to stand
up and reject the premise let's talk
about George Floyd you said George
Floyd's death was a terrible thing
terrible why are african-americans still
dying at the hands of law enforcement in
this country and so are white people
some are white people what a terrible
question to ask so are white people more
white people by the way more white
people a lot of people are criticizing
Trump for this response I actually kind
of liked this respond it wasn't the
perfect one I think the perfect response
would have been to reject the premise
about the cops to say actually the cops
aren't killing that many people there
are very few officer-involved killings
every year and they are not targeting
black people and you know
you could get to the second part about
how a lot of more white people are being
killed by the cops and you get to that
second I think he could have gone
further and just rejected the whole
thing about the cops and just defended
the blue but I do at least like the
point that he's not playing into this
fiction that black people are being
hunted down all around the country by
racist police that is a fiction the idea
that individualism and family and
Christianity and science and history and
working are exclusively white that is a
fiction the idea that we're living in a
white supremacist culture is a fiction
the idea that melanin gives you power
and that white people are animals and
savages is a fiction it's a lie no one
should give any quarter to this we've
talked a lot on this show about how you
cannot stand in the middle on these
issues these are very clear issues if
you stand in the middle of the road you
are going to get hit by a truck we are
in an election year you need clear
messaging clear positioning if you stand
in the middle of the road you are gonna
get run over by the people who are
running against you okay
so President Trump you can criticize his
response and say oh it wasn't wasn't
quite politic you could have massaged it
this way that's fine but at least he is
rejecting this fictional racial
narrative that is being pushed the
culture has become insane it beyond race
you know race is the hot topic right now
but it's become insane unsex - I meant
to get to this earlier in the week I'm
glad we can get to it now it this seems
like a trivial story this seems like it
doesn't matter but it it has
wide-ranging effects on the whole
culture and therefore on our politics
Will and Jada Smith Will Smith and Jada
Smith married for a long time they've
said they are not getting divorced
they've got a solid marriage let's just
come out that Jada Smith was dating some
other guy during their marriage and so
on Jada's show her social media show the
red table Will Smith came down and they
talked openly about infidelity within
their marriage we decided that we were
going to separate for a period of time
and
you go figure out how to make yourself
happy and I'll figure out how to make
myself well at that particular point in
time it was indefinite yeah I really
felt like we could be over yeah no we
were over and then what did you do Jada
well you know I think from there you
know as time went on I got into a
different kind of entanglement with
August and one thing I want to get clear
about and clean up one of the things
that was kind of swirling in the press
about you giving permission which is you
know the only person that could give
permission in in that particular
circumstance is myself
yes exactly yeah but what August was
probably trying to communicate mm-hmm
because I could actually see how he
would perceive it as permission because
we were separated amicably and I think
he also wanted to make it clear that
he's not a homewrecker which he's not oh
my gosh this is so awkward and most of
what she just said is not true I mean
she's right that she had this affair
with this guy but but her conclusions
about that are not true but it's so
awkward to watch this I don't want to
watch Will Smith admitting to being a
cuckold on camera and yet he's willing
to do that and it's it's engrossing
stuff and and in many ways we can give
these people some respect for coming out
and addressing these rumors that have
been swirling about infidelity within
the marriage particularly Jada Smith's
infidelity and so you give them a little
bit of credit for confronting this
head-on but it is so so awkward and it's
based on a misunderstanding of family
right she says in here what one of the
rumors was that Will Smith gave this guy
Auguste permission to sleep with his
wife and she's saying that's not what
happened and by the way you wouldn't be
the one to give permission I would be
the only one who could give permission
that's not true when you were married
and the wife wants to go sleep with some
other guy it is she does not have the
right she isn't she's not the one who
can do that and her her I guess her
husband could give permission but he
shouldn't
no this is no this is not sorry guys
this kind of hyper individualism this
total focus on the self is
extraordinarily destructive in this a
lot of what we're seeing here has
typifies leftist culture particularly on
sex and marriage but there was a little
glimmer of hope at the end the kind of
ironic Limor of Hope which is the
conclusion that they made which is that
they're not going to get divorced you
expect to be with somebody for a
lifetime 25 years and Counting we ride
together we got bad marriage for life so
obviously reference to two bad boys ride
together died together bad boys for life
bad marriage for life there's something
actually to be said about that you know
in in most of modern culture they would
just get divorced right the minute any
trouble happens you just split up and
you remarry and the Smiths have been
interesting because they won't do that
even though obviously they've fallen
prey to the same sort of troubles that
happen throughout Hollywood and really
happened to a lot of marriages anyway so
there's something really admirable there
you're seeing reaching for a kind of
more traditional culture the things that
typify leftist culture here is this
insistence on being transparent you
notice this reading the leftist
intellectuals throughout history they
always want to be really transparent
particularly about sex a lot of let you
know Karl Marx and Rousseau and a lot of
these people want to be very transparent
about their sexual exploits they want to
hear about their sexual partners
exploits this is a weird thing
conservatives don't want to do that just
like I don't tell me about your past
don't wanna hear about your ex-boyfriend
or your ex-girlfriend just shut up let's
move on now but they they want to be
very transparent I think part of this is
because they want they live by ideology
which is supposed to you know be
universally applicable and you know
they're living basically only on their
reason not on their gut you can see Will
Smith II he doesn't look happy to be
hearing about his wife's relationship
with this guy and yet he's still
listening to it and putting it on camera
I think if we couldn't correct this
problem of selfishness I've always
needed to be happy all the time of
following our individual appetites all
the time if we can if we can fix that
part and we can keep maybe learn a
lesson from this idea of you know good
marriage bad marriage we're in a
marriage we're not going to split up
that could be a path forward because it
seems like a trivial story but the
building block of society is the family
is the marriage that's why the left
attacks it as often as it does if you
don't have working marriages you won't
have a working society you won't have a
working politics there's actually
something to be learned
even from the obviously dysfunctional
marriage of Will and Jada Smith probably
we're going to get a lot of information
about dysfunctional marriages soon too
because Twitter was hacked yesterday
even some of the biggest accounts Joe
Biden Tesla Tesla CEO Elon Musk
Kanye West looks like Obama Bloomberg
and Bezos may have been affected -
totally took over these accounts
probably some nefarious actor state or
private has access to a lot of DMS we'll
see there on probably a lot more
transparency coming out soon as well and
speaking of private messages you've sent
me your mailbag questions we will get to
them in just one second but I've got to
thank all of you for subscribing to the
show on Apple podcasts and on YouTube be
sure to check out exclusive content
posted on that channel like my interview
with Dave Rubin which was just very
recent also Ben's got a new book get his
book it's called how to destroy America
in three easy steps when he wrote this
he foresaw things that are happening
right now it's very accurate great read
as always goes on sale Tuesday July 21st
at 6 p.m. Eastern 3 p.m. Pacific Ben
will be doing a virtual live signing
event on the day of release with your
purchase of a signed copy you can write
in a question which may be read and
answered as he signs your book live on
the air you can pre-order your signed
copy and writing your question daily
wire.com / Ben head on over to daily
wire and then come on back we've got a
whole lot more if you go get go get your
readers pass and be 99 cents per for the
first month then it'll be three dollars
per month after that you get a whole
bunch of stuff we'll be right back with
the mailbag
welcome back to the mailbag our first
sponsor to mailbag this week's mailbag
sponsored by the Benham brothers learn
how to own a business without yet owning
you get a 15% discount on the Benham
brothers new course expert ownership at
benin brothers dot-com / talent alright
let's jump right in from Ryan hi Michael
I was talking to a leftist friend of
mine
who said that the polls in 2016 weren't
wrong Hillary did have a 99 percent
chance of winning but Trump just hit
that 1 percent likelihood okay before I
go insane can you tell me that leftists
deep down don't believe anything they
say and that they don't really trust the
mainstream media this blindly now they
do I mean this is the issue with with
polling is you're always right whatever
happens you can always be right and you
can always defend you're wrong
predictions by saying well I was just I
believe part of the lower chance and it
did work then you look in the various
states and they'll say look Trump he
really barely won he didn't really he
didn't even really win just you know
100,000 votes go this way in one state
under doesn't votes go that way in
another state and that's why he won yep
uh-huh that's what the polls are
supposed to tell us and then moreover
you know there weren't polls that said
99 percent of people are going to vote
for Hillary Clinton what where we got
this 99 percent number is there were a
lot of analyses at this polls of all of
these polls that said okay looking at
all the polls seems 97 or 99 percent
likely that that Donald Trump will lose
say well I guess that want that 1%
member came in it's very difficult to
trust these polls particularly now we
mentioned earlier people are just afraid
to talk to pollsters so you know the the
polling matters in as much as the
campaign's should be paying attention to
this and not getting complacent at all
but if you're actually gonna you know if
you're gonna bet the house on something
you read in the polls I think you'd
probably be a foolish gambler from Jack
Michael just signed up for the daily
wire so I could tell you this a couple
weeks ago my wife's cousin in LA went to
get tested for kovat he filled out the
paperwork and waited over three hours
before deciding to leave then a few days
later he got a call from the clinic
telling him he tested positive for kovat
19 he was never tested I thought it was
crazy but I gave them the benefit of the
doubt maybe a clerical error until I
told my good friend here in Texas about
what happened
and he said you're not gonna believe
this T Our Mutual Friend told me the
exact same thing happened to him he also
got that phone call telling him he
tested positive for code that even
though he had left the clinic before
getting tested question would you
consider these isolated incidents
smoking gun were just a coincidence I
always thought kovat numbers were skewed
how can I believe any data at this point
your newest fan came for Ben's stayed
for the khofifah yeah this is a thanks
for sending in that story because
obviously you know we're looking for
data here but if the plural of anecdote
given often enough is data and we do
know that there has been a lot of
madness I mean people who have been shot
and died from gunshot wounds have been
listed as Cova deaths and there have
been lots of different tests for kovat
and there's been a lot of contradictory
information that's come out from the so
called public health experts and the
mainstream media and we know that this
has been extraordinarily politicized and
we also know that that medical providers
are receiving more money from in for the
form of government funding based on
their their work with kovat patients so
I don't know if any of these particular
examples you're using our accurate or if
they're misunderstood or if there's
confusion but but surely the the basic
thing we can say here is that when
you're looking at the co vid reporting
you need to be skeptical does that mean
there's some nefarious SuperDuper
conspiracy maybe there could be you know
the reason that conspiracies conspiracy
theories catch on is because every so
often there are conspiracies you know
you're these conspiracies about I
remember I used to reject this
completely outright they'd say there is
a conspiracy out there that a bunch of
elite wealthy powerful people in in
government heads of state the royal
family or they're all there are
pedophiles among them and they have this
pedophile ring and I'd say oh yeah
that's so ridiculously and that's so
crazy so every so often you know that
that's how the the crazier theories
propagate so I don't know what's
happening with qoph it all I can caution
you is you ought to be skeptical and the
people who try to shame you and bully
you for being skeptical of what you're
hearing on any particular given
from the medical establishment that
maybe they're gonna change their mind on
in two days the people who were bullying
you about that are probably the least to
be trusted of anybody from Josh dear mr.
Knowles what if we try actually putting
the left on defense by calling canceled
culture the KKK canceled culture club
with this end the movement no no it
wouldn't it's kind of funny I mean I get
a kick out of it but that it would not
end anything Republicans have tried this
strategy for at least the past couple of
decades maybe longer which is to respond
to the baseless charges of racism by
saying Democrats are the real racists
you're I'm the least racist you are the
most racist as as if this would shame
the Democrats into into either changing
their mind or cutting out the baseless
attacks it won't they don't care
they've first of all they've redefined
racism to just mean whatever they think
right so racism which once had a meaning
aside this idea of of discriminating
against people being harsh against
people attacking people based explicitly
on the color of their skin now has been
transformed to anything white people do
anything white people do is racist and
by the way when black people exhibit
racism that's not racist because they're
black I mean it's just it's in the Nick
Cannon example so the word no longer
means anything other than something a
leftist doesn't like and so you're not
going to be able to convince them and
and I don't think they're interested
anyway
Republicans god bless him they still
think that we're in an Arab thirty years
ago where you could have some kind of
reasonable debate that's not what's
going on we are in a bare-knuckle brawl
for our government for our politics the
left has admitted this I mean they now
deny objective truth right they're
saying another one of these sheets about
white culture so that objective truth is
a white concept science
this one says science is a white concept
so you're not going to be able to deal
with an American left that denies the
universality of reason and truth this is
going this
this election in November is not going
to be about convincing these people in
the middle I don't think that's what
it's about I think it's going to be much
more like the George Bush 2004
reelection campaign it's gonna be about
turning out the bass you've got to turn
out the bass and that's that's all we're
gonna do rather than try to argue and
convince people on the other side that
you're not a terrible person you have
got to rally and encourage your own side
from Sean I saw quite possibly the most
leftist article from 12 news in Arizona
today the headline was will Christmas be
called off by kovat 19 do you think they
have a chance of taking Christmas from
us - or will it wear off before then
thank you for all that you do they've
been trying to take Christmas away from
us since the first Christmas let's not
forget King Herod was trying to take
Christmas away he was chatting with
those Magi trying to figure out a way to
snuff out the first Christmas before it
had barely begun we've had the war on
Christmas here which the left mocks as
though it didn't exist meanwhile they
renamed all the Christmas trees holiday
trees and they they take merry Christmas
out of public marketing and they make it
about season's greetings so they all
they all engage in how they've been
trying to do that for many years and now
sure I'm sure they are certainly going
to try to shut down travel and not have
people go visit their relatives for
Christmas you know it's important to
fight back against this culture and we
want to have a politics in a culture
that are safe for Christianity for the
exercise of religion but we should also
acknowledge while we're doing that that
the popular culture this world the
Prince of Darkness of this world has
always been trying to stop that and so
you know you shouldn't just complain and
whine and despair about it you should
fight back and try to make a better
culture in politics for the religion but
you know it sort of was ever thus from
Kris cigar master Noel's if a
nine-year-old can have the agency to
change their gender then wouldn't a
nine-year-old have the agency to make
the choice to go back to school
according to leftist logic of course but
goes actually further than that that
this the left's argument on transgender
children has cutting against their
argument about liberal adults you know
yeah one thing we've heard in recent
years about the campuses is that there's
an epidemic of rape and
one in four women are to be raped which
would make Harvard Yard more dangerous
for women than Fallujah I don't think
anybody really believes that that is the
case what they're talking about is well
college kids drink and then they go hook
up you know they have these kind of
increasingly you know clinical sexual
interactions that that you know because
of free love and sexual liberation that
this is just to be expected and then
sometimes the next morning one one or
more of the parties will have regret and
then they'll say that was rape you know
I was drunk or I didn't want to do that
or even though I did want to do that now
I don't want to do that so what they're
effectively saying is that a
nine-year-old has sufficient mental
faculties to make life-changing sexual
decisions but a 22 year old does not
have the mental faculties to make
temporary sexual decisions right a
nine-year-old has the mental faculties
to permanently alter his body chemistry
in a way that can never be corrected but
a 22 year old woman can't have a
one-night stand that doesn't make any
sense but the left has to preserve the
cult of sexual liberation the left has
to preserve the cult of individual
autonomy maximizing individual autonomy
and the left has to preserve the cult of
feminist victimhood
you can't you can't have all of those at
once it's the say you know the trans
issue is just such a wedge here because
the left has told us for years and years
that homosexuals are born that way and
no one should tell them to suppress
their desires and how dare you that you
know a man loving another man sexually
is totally natural and actually
inescapable and who would choose this
and also there's no such thing as men or
women well there's no such thing as men
or women there's no such thing as
objective sex immutable sex then there's
no such thing as homosexuality
homosexuality requires there to be
immutable sexes they haven't dealt with
that and they I'm not holding my breath
for them to deal with that
it's just another incoherent aspect of
their ideology that's not going to
probably change through reason to debate
you're just using it as a political
cudgel from Nik austere religious
podcast right so that you and the Lord
of the multiverse Andrew Clayman did a
review of Hamilton I was wondering if
you will be doing other reviews and
similar topics such as movies and TV
shows I'm asking because I was unable to
watch the musical Hamilton since I both
a man and straight thank you I guess
that relates to the previous question as
well yes I I hope so I had a great time
doing that with Drew because we just
went over and smoked cigars and had a
good time which we do anyway let me know
in the comments if there's something in
the culture you think we should watch I
need a new show anyway it's been you
know it's been a long week for a lot of
people long several weeks along several
months we're now a hundred and twenty
two days since we were told 15 days to
slow the spread some of us knew it
wasn't really going to be 15 days anyway
so that's all we're doing trapped in our
homes watching TV unless we take the
opportunity before us we realize that
politics is not inevitable the political
outcomes that the left ones that we can
actually change our political future if
only we have the courage to act that's
our show i'm michael knowles as the
michael nul show see you Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
Boren supervising producers Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling technical
producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders hair
and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen